now the works of the flesh are
manifested which are these adultery
fornication uncleanliness lavishness
idolatry witchcraft hatred and
as i have also told you in time past that they
which do such things shall not inherit the
kingdom of god but the spirit is love joy peaceful
suffering gentleness goodness faith commitment
and help us to learn more about you
and help us not to forget what we
our subject for this evening
direction is everything what did i say
with the word of god in his hands every human
being wherever his lot in life may be cast
may have such companionship as he shall choose in
its pages he may hold converse with the noblest
and best of the human race and may listen to
the voice of the eternal as he speaks with men
as he studies and meditates upon the
themes into which the angels desire to look
he may have their companionship he may
follow the steps of the heavenly teacher
and listen to his words as when he taught on
mountain and plain and sea he may dwell in this
world in the atmosphere of heaven imparting to
earth's soldering tempted ones thoughts of hope
and longings for holiness himself coming closer
and still closer into fellowship with the unseen
like him of old who walk with god drawing nearer
and nearer the threshold of the eternal world
until the portal shall open and he shall
enter there he will find himself no stranger
the voices that will greet him are the voices
of the holy ones voices who unseen were on earth
his companions voices that here he learned to
distinguish and to love he who through the word
of god has lived in fellowship with heaven will
find himself at home in heaven's companionship
education page 127 paragraph
one god is good and all the time
thank god for preserving us up to this point
during this day the holy day is gone am i right
but the sun never sets on your
holiness are you with me the sun
does not set on our personal holiness we are still
holy people regardless of whatever plans you may
have made for tonight we are still holy people the
sun does not set on that so please remember that
let me thank god again for the high high honor
of being asked to speak for him i know i don't
know why he chose me but uh i'm glad he did and
so i will try to represent him as best i can by
presenting to you thus saith the lord where is it
is what's our friend over here carla where is she
she went home well tell her the preacher
missed her would you tell her that
tell her that please where are my other two
sisters who were here last night beverly ah
blessings upon you who else yes give me the name
susan yes thank you so much for staying
with us i really mean that from my heart
and may god bless you and when i come back i want
to know that you're members of the church say amen
say it again one more time god is good and all
the time how many of you love god can i see your
hand you love god hands down do you really
love god when was the last time you told him
what did you say what did you say what
did you say you told him i love you
all right you know god loves to hear that not just
wives and girlfriends god loves to hear i love you
i like you all right our subject for this evening
direction is everything what did i say as always
if you have a form please make sure it
does not ring in the presence of a holy god
let me explain why i paused so long before
i start i'm waiting for you to sit still
i've observed a lot of getting up and
moving around and i just wonder why
is it a lack of discipline
i sit and i don't move just
i'm a guest so i have to be careful
i don't want to be arrested but uh
it um you have to make up your mind how many of
you ever take the s.a.t can i show your hands
did you walk around the room did you get up all
the time you sat for three hours and you took
it i'm sure dr mcnulty took the usmle step
one and two you sat there and you took it
hi okay so much for that favor number two
while i'm speaking pray for me and say lord
put your words in that man's mouth
that is based on what bible verse
one what nine which says what
then the lord put forth his hand and touch my
mouth and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth please pray that
prayer for me i mean it very very seriously
and favor number three think
that's based on what bible verse
the first part of that verse says what come
now let us read now let me give an example of
god calling us to reason you know this verse if
thou has run with the foot man and they have what
where is they how then can't thou contend with
the horses this is god calling us to think
a large component of bible
religion is common sense
guided by the holy ghost if you cannot
keep up with a man how do you expect
to keep up with a horse there are 168 hours
in the week if you spend only two in church
and 60 on social media how do
you plan to be ready for jesus
let's pray father in heaven
come close to me please the holy spirit
literally sit in my mouth and speak
i voluntarily choose to humble myself
before you if i had wings i would fold them
and i ask you today god as an act of mercy speak
through me i make no claims to righteousness
holiness or goodness but as i stand in this desk
i recommit my life to you completely for service
help me to speak simply directly
and let your people whom you love so much
understand what you're saying through me
father bless this country elij says it is the
most blessed country the sun has ever shone upon
but it will one day speak with the voice of a
dragon but bless it now and while opportunity
still exists let us do all we can to advance
the gospel bless the leaders of this country
bless the president father because the bible says
let every soul be subject unto the higher powers
for there is no power but of god the powers
that be are ordained of god bless that man
bless the senators blessed congressmen and women
bless governors blessed mayors best city managers
father let all the decisions somehow
be advantageous to the gospel
bless the pastor of this church bless this
conference and conferences represented by this
gathering of the saints keep your hand over
the seventh day out on this church dear god
the devil attacks it with ferocity
it will stumble it will totter
but we have the confidence and assurance it will
not fall now lord let this message make some small
contribution to someone's spiritual life take
all the glory and give us the blessing i pray
this from my heart in jesus name let god's
people say amen and amen our subject is what
okay come on in those of you
who are coming come on in
let's take a look at the degree to which christ
took our sins let us go to first peter chapter 2
we read verse 24. i read from the
king james version of the bible
first peter chapter 2 verse 24. do you have that
if you have my version you may read with me
who his own self bear our sins where in his
own body on the tree the tree being a reference
to the cross let's look at that verse again
microscopically who his own self bear our sins
where in his own body he took our sins into him
as the good doctor said this is
no vicarious act he took our sins
into him let's go to one of the most important
verses in all the bible second corinthians
chapter 5 verse 21 our subject direction
is everything second corinthians 5 21.
for he hath made him to be sin for us whom you
know sin that we might be made the righteousness
of god in him we read that again by the way when
you study the bible whatever verse you're studying
or passage read it many times not just once read
it as if nothing else in the world exists but you
and that text and the holy ghost concentrate on
what you're reading for he have made him to be sin
for us who is he is not jesus who is he in that
verse god the father he hath made him who is him
jesus christ to be sin for us now right after us
says who knew no sin who knew no sin jesus not us
that we might be made who does the making.
are you sure it's god this is the second time
we see make in that word whether to make or made
the first time it's used who's doing the making
who's doing the making the second time god still
god still god for he god hath made him to be sin
that's a strong statement
it's also a statement that gives me great
comfort regarding the purity of christ
for he hath made him to be sin now we
heard earlier this morning we don't
believe in original sin because sin is a choice
are you with me sin is a choice
listen to the verse and keep the
concept of choice in your mind
for he the father hath made him to be
sin he is sin on the cross that is sin
god only curses sin are you with me god only
turns away from sin the only reason why people die
is because of sin by the way people don't die
of her potential and diabetes we die of sin
whether sin we committed or just
living in a sinful world or coming
into life with a fallen name we die because of sin
you have made him to be sin for us question for
you why did god have to make him to be sin for us
now we have god and we have him who is
him jesus god made him to be sin for us
why did god do that
okay let me ask you this if you were
let's say dr norman was walking down
the steps and i held his hand to
walk him down what might he say to me
what might he say he's a grown man physically
fit and i'm taking his hand helping him down
the stairs what might he say to me nicely i can
do that myself are you with me i can do that
myself now for he god hath made him to be seen
question for you could jesus have made himself sin
why not why not ah if he had chosen someone
else had to make him sin because he did
not make himself sin in other words he
never chose to sin he had to be made sin
follow me closely that's one half
of the algebraic formula there
look at the other half that we might be made we
have to be made righteous first finish my words
come on finish my words no no no no no
listen listen microscopically the father
made him to be sin he had to be made sin
because in him was no sin all right concentrate
now we are made righteous finish my words
because there's no righteousness in us
thank you for that isolated amen
he had to be made sin
because he never chose to sin
we have to be made righteous because there is
not one iota of righteousness in us naturally
what does the bible say jesus himself
said that which is born of the flesh
is flesh what else did he say it is the spirit
that quickeneth john 6 63 the flesh profiteth
nothing what did paul say i know that in
me that is in my flesh dwelleth no good
thing all right i got a question for you
before i well let me ask you the
question now you don't have to answer
how could jesus take all the sins
into him how could he be made sin
how could he be someone who had all our
infirmities familiar with them and yet remain pure
how can we have a sinful nature
and still live a pure life
let's pray again holy father in
heaven as a as i handle truth
and the carnal nature cannot originate truth
speak through me there god give me simplicity
of language let me seek your glory not mine in
jesus name i plead amen go with me to mark 7.
we'll read microscopically
closely it's 21 minutes to 8. you've had a
long day can you give me to 8 15 yes or no
all right thank you for being gracious
god bless you what book did i say
what book did i say mark 7 is not a book what
book did i say ah concentrate now what chapter
ah you're nice people you're good looking
god bless you mark 7 reading from verse 14.
when he found it say amen and when
he had called all the people unto him
he said unto them hearken unto me every one
of you finish the verse and understand now
is jesus telling us the same
thing yes why do you hesitate yes
he tells us hearken unto me that's what you
do when you read the bible and understand
next verse there is nothing did you do you
read that in your version there is nothing
come on read with me from without a man that
entering into him can define him but what
the things which come out of him those are
there that defy the man we'll read that
verse again there is nothing stop
what does nothing exclude nothing
there is nothing from without a man that entering
into him can defile him but the things which come
out of him those are they that defy the man if
any man have ears to hear let him hear and when
he was entered into the house from the people his
disciples asked him concerning the parables and
he said unto them he saith unto them are ye so
without understanding also read with me now do
ye not perceive that what whatsoever from without
entereth into the man come on it cannot defile him
here's his explanation i'll keep reading
because it entereth not into his heart
but into the belly and goeth out into
the draft pushing all me jesus says
look in order for something from outside to
defile you it has to enter into the heart
there is nothing now verse 20 read with me and
he said what that which cometh out of the man
that defileth the man stop we read it again
how is a man defiled what comes out of him
that which cometh out of the man
that defileth now we know he's talking about moral
defilement sin how do we know that let's keep
reading for from within out of the heart of man
proceed what evil thoughts adulteries fornications
murders thefts consciousness wickedness
deceit lasciviousness an evil lie blasphemy
pride foolishness all these evil things come from
within and define the man now matthew gives the
same story and matthew ends by saying but to
eat with unwashing hands defileth not a man
if you eat a pork chop you're not
morally defiled by the pork chop
the decision to eat it came from your heart
that's the defilement
god made pigs i imagine and god saw
everything that he had made and behold it was
very good whatever purpose they were made to
fulfill that's good and you drink coffee you
know by the way there's some adventures
to say what's wrong with a cup of coffee
if god said what's wrong with a little fruit
that's what vegetarians do but look at us today
for from within
your husband can't make you the witch of endor
you have to choose to be that
your wife can't make you first
cousin table rabbis you have to choose that
yes they can create stressful environments
for you your boss can't make you a demon
because the pharma doesn't go from the outside
in finish my words it goes from the inside
all right if that's clear say amen anyone
confused all right let's go to leviticus 1.
leviticus 1 what is jesus doing now
what's going what began in 1844 october 22 the
cleansing of the what and i said this morning this
has to be cleansed first are you with me all right
let's go leviticus one we'll read from verse one
third book of the bible if you can condense
leviticus to one word it would be holiness
do you have that let me pray father be with me
i enter into this phase of the message be with
me dear god please in jesus name amen and the
lord called unto moses and spake unto him out of
the tabernacle of the congregation saying speak
unto the children of israel and say unto them
if any man if you bring an offering to the lord he
shall bring the offering of the cattle even of the
herd and of the flo cattle being bulls the herd
being domestic animals flock being sheep all right
if this offering be a burnt sacrifice
of the herd let him what offer a mail
with our blemish he shall offer it come on of his
own voluntary will at the door of the tabernacle
of the congregation before the lord let's read
verse 3 again read that for me what does that say
if his offering be a burnt sacrifice of the
herd come on let him offer a male without
blemish what's the spiritual
equivalent of without blemish
without sin because the animal
represents it represents jesus
all right verse 4 read with me and he
shall do what put his hand upon the
head of the burnt offering and it shall
be accepted for him to make atonement
for him now what is the significance of placing
his hands on the head of the burnt offer
let the bible explain leviticus 16 verse 20.
our subject direction is everything it's a quarter
to eight i asked for 8 15. i may let y'all before
because it's been a long day for you and for me
for all of us but we thank god for the freedom
to assemble and worship can you say amen you
thank god we're still alive i've never seen a dead
tired man can you can you follow what i'm trying
to say i've never seen a dead person who was tired
it's a privilege to be tired it means your life
you don't believe what i'm saying okay it's a
privilege to feel cold you're alive leviticus 16
reading verse 20. are you there
read with me what does that say
come on read lies a lot and when he hath made an
end of reconciling what the holy place and the
tabernacle of the congregation and the altar he
shall do what bring the life god by the way let
me pause some people say some churches maybe
that that that as a azzazeel represents jesus
no notice the verse says when he has made
the end of reconciling the holy place
the tablet of the congregation and
the altar when all reconciliation
by christ is done that's when we get
to the goat that represents azazil
verse 21 nice and clear and loud come
on and aaron shall lay both his hands
upon the of the life god and shall confess
over him come on all the iniquities
of the children of israel come on and
all the transgressions in all their sins
putting them upon the head of the goat stop
now so this symbolizes a transfer of sin
we go back to chapter one
verse four
are you there read with me and he shall put
his hand upon the head of the burnt offering
and it shall be accepted for him to make
atonement for him let's read five and go on down
and he shall kill the bullock before the lord and
aaron the priest shall do one bring his blood and
spring his blood roundabout on the altar that is
by the door of the tabernacle of the congregation
verse six and he shall flay the burnt
offering come on and cut it into his pieces
what does the word flay mean to skin and he shall
flee that's the sinner the burnt offering and cut
it into his pieces verse 7 and the sons of aaron
the priest shall do what put fire upon the altar
and lay the word how in order upon by the way the
word couldn't be placed anyway it had to be placed
in order when you worship god that worship must
be orderly the way you sing must be orderly
everything must be orderly this goes all the way
back to abraham before when god called abraham
and told him sacrifice isaac i believe verse
9 of genesis the bible says and abraham came
to the place which god had told him of and he
built an altar there and laid the wood in order
on the altar disorderly
worship is offensive to god
disciplined worship every person in
his or her place at the right time
know why armies look so beautiful when they
march when they parade everyone is in step
but i'll leave that alone verse 7 and the sons
of aaron the priest shall put fire upon the
altar and lay the wood in order under fire
now read verse eight for me and the priest
aaron shan come on shall lay the parts the
head and the fat come on upon the altar come on
which is upon the all right so the
parts are laid but read verse 9
what does that say but he shall but the
inwards and the legs come on shall he wash stop
the animal had to be according to verse 3 without
blemish how was the man to know it had no blemish
he looked at it he is sin his household is sin
he picks a lamb he's going to the tabernacle it
has no no broken legs no another lamb didn't
tear off the ear he looked no blemishes where
on the outside but god is more concerned with
but he wants blemishes nowhere so the animal
comes no blemishes on the outside but the
inside has to be checked so verses verse 6 says
and he shall fled the burnt offering and cut it
into his pieces verse 9 says but the inwards and
the legs shall he wash make sure there's nothing
inside that's unclean as children of god we have
to be clean finish my words inside and outside
all the work of sanctification is not complete
all right but his inwards and his leg shall be
washed with water and the prey shall burn on all
the all on the altar to be a burnt sacrifice
an offering made by fire of sweet savour unto
the lord with one blemish it would not be a
sweet savor because sin does not smell nice
what's our subject
what question are we trying to answer
how could christ take all our sins and
remain pure let's go back to verse 4
of leviticus 1.
read with me and he shall put his hand
upon the head of the burnt offering
and it shall be accepted for him
to make atonement for him okay
what does that symbolize placing the hand on
the head of the animal transfer of what sin
before i ask you the next question let's
go back to mark i hope you don't mind
running from book to book let's go
back to mark chapter 7 reread from 20.
mark 7 verse 20 and i continue to ask god to speak
through me as i speak to his people i hope someone
has already prayed for me in the congregation
and said lord put your words in that man's mouth
it's a desperate need that i have jesus said what
and he said that which cometh out of the man that
defileth the man for from within out of the
heart of man proceed what does proceed mean
yeah trap yeah yeah travel out yeah proceed from
the heart you see from within it proceeds it
goes out evil thoughts adulteries fornications
murders thefts consciousness wickedness deceit
lasciviousness an evil eye blasphemy pride
foolishness now we have to believe that list is
not exhausted because the bible says now the works
of the flesh are manifest which are these adultery
fornication uncleanness lasciviousness idolatry
witchcraft hatred variance emulations wrath strife
seditions heresies envyings murders drunkness
revelings and such like meaning the list can go
on and on but however long the list is
it comes from here and causes defilement
its choice yes now go back to leviticus 1.
5 to 8.
read verse 4 with me now you read it i'll listen
to you king james people read it and he shall
stop what does that symbolize
all right quiz question number one
in what direction is the sin traveling
when the sinner puts his head on the animal
pause pause pause let me
ask you a different question
after the sinner has confessed his sins
on that animal is the animal still pure
does the animal represent jesus is jesus
pure after the sinner has confessed
over that animal is the animal still pure
would you like to change your mind
all those who say it's still
pure let me see your hands
those who say it is now defiled with those
sins let me see your health all right
listen this is serious listen to
me carefully no listen to the bible
and he shall place his hands upon the head
of the burnt offering or the sacrifice
transferring sins where is the
sinner in relation to the the animal
he's outside the animal are you listening to me
you're not listening to me are you listening to me
he is outside the animal huh where are the sins
going symbolically in what direction from come on
in what direction from the outside in what did
jesus say there is nothing from without a man
that entering into him can defile him
so when he confess all his sins upon that
animal symbolically the animal remained pure
because the things did not come from the
animal's heart it came from the outside in
what's your subject
now let's go back to jesus
who his own self bear our sins
in his own body huh in the body
where did the sins have to come from
outside and travel in what direction
in what did jesus say nothing going
from outside in come on can defile
and so christ can take the sins of the world
finish my words and remain come on pure
only divinity can arrange that plan
now
that purity of the christ that christ lived
on this earth is the purity required of us
notice my words carefully the purity
of the life of christ on earth
is the purity required of us
this let's this let the bible describe this heart
jeremiah 79 don't go there just say it the heart
is deceitful above all things and desperately
wicked who can know it that's this we're born with
that jeremiah 13 23 don't go there just saying can
the ethiopian change his skin other leopards his
spots then may he also do good that are accustomed
to do evil the word the answer is no you cannot
it's impossible let's go to romans eight seven and
eight don't go don't go there say it because the
carnal mind is enmity against god for it's not
subject to the law of god neither indeed can be
it is impossible for the carnal heart to obey god
deceitful above all things cannot change its spots
even if you painted stripes on a leopard
it's still spotted you know
why it is spotted in the jeans
so you put high priestly robes on a sinner he's
still a sinner you put a pig in a palace still
a pig because it is genetically determined
now because this is the heart that we have
christ has to change it
so out of it comes not sin but that
which pleases god are you following me
because defilement goes from
thee so does righteousness
elohim writes the law that seeketh not its own
has its source in the heart of god that's where
it came from a good man out of the good treasure
of his heart bringing forth good things as verily
as sin and defilement flow from the fallen heart
out righteousness flows from the renewed heart out
listen to what god does jeremiah 31 verse 33
what's our subject quickly the direction is
everything jeremiah 31 let's go there we'll
read verse 33 it's 8 o'clock on the dot
jeremiah the weeping prophet what's the
nickname for isaiah the gospel prophet yes
he wrote so much about jesus all of isaiah
58 is about jesus 53 sorry elohim says read
it every day it will humble you
isaiah 53 what chapter did i say
jeremiah 31 reading verse 33 let me pray father
continue to be with me as i have 15 minutes left
in jesus name i pray amen where are my king
james people read nice and loud and clear what
does this say but this shall be the covenant that
i will make with the house of israel after they
say saith the lord read slowly i will do what
where come on ann stop i will put my law where
and write it where virtually the same thing
put all right inward parts of the heart same
thing now what else does god write on the heart
well we just read that so my
question is what else does he write
now the verse says i'll put my laws in the inward
parts what else does he write in the inward parts
nothing
all he puts finish my words is the law
are you following me that's all he posts
now listen to what the effect the law
truly written in the heart the effect it has
on the person go to not leviticus malachi 2.
malachi 2.
the last book of the old testament book 39
it's a beautiful book read malachi is this back
and forth between god and the israelites god
says one thing they say when did we do that god
said something else when did we do that god says
something else when did we do that and that hasn't
changed among us one bit malachi 2 verse 6. god
is talking about the levites called to be priest
teachers of the law do you have malachi 2 verse 6
read microscopically what does this say the law of
truth was in his mouth stop that's levi as a tribe
read the next statement an iniquity was not found
in his lips now practically speaking is lips
different from mouth in that verse no you need
to understand something called hebrew parallelism
you say the same thing
differently let me give an example
jacob also went down into egypt now israel also
entered into egypt and jacob's surgeon in the
sergeant in the land of ham who is jacob israel
what is egypt the land of hell it's the same thing
expressed differently here's another example by
the word of the lord where the heavens made all
the hosts of them by the breath of his mouth same
thing another example for he spake it was done
he commanded it stood fast speak and commanded
are not two different things god did are you
with me now you're not with me are you
with me now let's go back to malachi 2 6.
concentrate the law of
truth was where in his mouth
then what could not be in his lips
iniquity why because the law was there
his mouth was full of the law
so there was no room for inequity
the problem with us the law is not really written
on our hearts it's in the bible on our shelves
because where the law truly exists
sin cannot exist as a lifestyle
the law of truth was in his mouth
iniquity was not found in his lips
if sin is regularly found in my heart
the law is not really written there
why could jesus live a victorious life i
delight to do thy will o my god finish the words
yea thy law is within my heart and
the will of god is the law of god
let me say it again the will of god
condensed summarized is the law of god
go to romans 2. let's read from verse 17 direction
is everything it's 7 after 8. i have 8 minutes
romans 2 reading from verse 17.
are you there my people read with me
behold thou art called a jew come on and
rest us in the law and make his divorce of god
and noises will come on and approve us the things
that are more excellent finish the verse being
instructed out of the law the law is god's will
a proof is the things that more excellent
means knowing how to determine what's good from
what's bad what's genuine faults what's right
what's wrong being instructed out of the law
now
when jesus said for from within out of
the heart of man proceed evil thoughts
adulteries fornications murders thefts cut
the whole list that's the unconverted heart
are you with me let's look at the
galatians 5 we look at the switch
the transfer from unconverted to convert it and
see the difference in what emerges from the heart
galatians 5 we read 19-23 that was
our scripture reading galatians
5. do you have that
galatians 5 galatians 5. read with me but the
works of the flesh are manifest which are these
adultery fornication uncleanness lasciviousness
idolatry witchcraft hatred variants emulations
wrath strife seditions heresies envyings murders
drunkenness revelings and such like everything
of the which i have told you before as i've
also told you in time past that they come on
which do such things shall not inherit the kingdom
of god keep going but the fruit of the spirit is
love joy peace long suffering gentleness
goodness faith meekness temperance come on
against such there is no law now when it
says there is no law against it it doesn't
mean there is no law in existence there is
no law against it because the law is for it
now look again adultery fornication verse 19
to 21 those are the works of the flesh the
flesh isn't this the flesh is this nature
are you with me that's what it produces
when we're converted and we walk by the
spirit something else comes from the inside
what's that love joy from the inside out
you combine that to one word righteousness
both come from the inside and so jesus
could take all our sins and remain sinless
because no sin traveled from the inside out
with christ they travel from the outside in
and he said there's nothing from without
a man entering into him can define him
we have a savior who mysteriously took
our sins into him and remained sinless
because he never chose to sin through the
process of justification maintained through
sanctification or forgiveness as my brother
said earlier we can choose the heart of christ
and despite the fact we're still possessed we
still possess not possessed by we still possess
a carnal nature out of our new
hearts will come love joy peace
because god will have written his law on our
hearts go to second corinthians 3 is 10 after 8.
second corinthians three let's read verse three
do you have that all right one more prayer father
in heaven the end is near don't end your help
continue to be with me lord because in the final
minutes the devil may twist my tongue in jesus
name i pray amen do you have second corinthians
3 3 read with me what does this say my king james
people for as much as you manifestly declared
to be the epistles of christ stop we should all
be epistles of christ read by the world are you
with me letters of love letters of righteousness
letters of the character of christ written by
uh read by the world come on ministered by us
now read carefully microscopically and
keep your mind on the writing of the law
on the tables of stone at sinai are you
with me keep reading not within come on
but with the spirit of the living god keep going
not tables of stone come on but on fleshy tables
of the heart what paul is saying the law by
the spirit is written not on stone but here
by the way it was the holy ghost
that read that wrote the law on stone
i don't have time to show you that it's
easily shown it was the holy you see
the father required the law to be spoken
christ was his agent in creation and salvation
christ is the agent of the father christ literally
spoke commandments the holy spirit wrought them
so the whole family of heaven was involved
in giving the commandments are you with me
the the holy spirit that wrote
the commandments on stone
is the one who writes the
commandments on our hearts
and what else was written on those stones
nothing because all god wants is obedience
listen to the bible these words are
from the wisest man who ever lived
let us hear the conclusion of the whole matter
fear god and keep his commandments finish it
so this is the whole duty of
me in other words god says
i require nothing from you that
falls outside the ten commands
condensed to two principles
love for god love for man
and because we have a fallen mind by birth
we can't grasp a divine law so we can
justifiably ask god how do i love my neighbor how
do i do this respect your parents don't kill don't
commit adultery don't steal don't lie don't covet
these are expressions of love to your neighbor
because our carnal minds couldn't how do
i love god god says here's how you love me
have no one else before me don't take my name
in vain don't worship idols don't make them
don't worship them don't take my name in vain
and keep the sabbath that's how you love me
he writes that's right here so the heart on which
the lord is written loves god and loves people
and those whom we love we don't hurt what does
the bible say love worketh no ill to his neighbor
no ill that's why love is the
fulfilling of the law what's our subject
in what direction does defilement
flow from the inside out
repent of that sin from the inside out let me
ask again in what direction does defilement flow
from the inside out where does adultery
come from where does uh theft come from
backbiting lusting pride where
does righteousness come from
from the heart given by god not the one
you're born with now let's ask god father
rewrite your law on my heart sometimes
when the document is old the ink fades
well no one knows what ink is because
we type everything on ipads but
in my day you use pens and the ink would
fade we want god to rewrite the law tonight
by his spirit we don't want him to write it we
want him to etch it you know what etching is
it's etch it's dug into the
material writing you just
you can't erase etching just like that
with a rubber with an eraser you can
you want it etched how many of you will say
with me father etch your lawn my heart tonight
and right now can i show your hand do you
mean that yes or no stand up with me etch it
and that goes for all ages
god wants to write his law on your heart how
old are you ten jesus was ten how old are you
jesus was 12 and the doctors couldn't answer him
he could recite genesis or revelation all 66
when he was 12. we're standing to say father
etch your law on my heart believe he'll do it
you know why first john 5 14 and this is the
confidence that we have in him that if we ask
anything according to his will he doeth it if
there's one thing that's god's will it is writing
the law on our hearts heads bowed eyes closed
therefore in heaven if i
misrepresented you i apologize to you
my desire was to present the truth as simply as
possible but father no human effort can be fully
satisfactory and so i ask you to go through
the spirit take this meager effort of mine
somehow make it meaningful to your people as you
re-emphasize it in their minds as they travel
god father of jesus and our father etch your
law in our hearts anew right now not us don't
do this and don't do that but as love for you and
love our fellow man father no one has to tell a
loving mother there's a law that says thou shalt
feed thy baby she feeds that baby even if she dies
that's the way love works when love is in the
heart they're god it directs us it teaches us
please god let from our hearts converted
flow the principles of righteousness
bless your people bowing in your presence
father remind them how much you love them
the most popular verse in your book says for
god so loved the world that he gave his only
begotten son the first does not say for god
so loved his son that he gave up the world
but for god so loved the world that he gave up his
son that is love we cannot understand but father
when we realize to some degree how much you love
us we consider the accuracy of first john 4 19
we love him because he first loved us let us
leave this place believing that your law has
been re-etched in our hearts to god so if
anything befalls us on the way we behave
like a righteous person watch over and says
we sleep god because the devil never sleeps
he tries to take our lives during the night
let a mighty angel stand by every bedside
bring us back tomorrow father a little spiritually
stronger than we are now bring us back tomorrow
strong i pray to close of this blessed weekend and
if we dream let us dream of jesus in his name we
pray let god's people say amen and amen now by the
grace of our lord jesus christ and the love of god
and the fellowship of the holy spirit be with us
now and forevermore let god's people say amen and
amen god bless you sleep well dream of jesus keep
the speed limit and we'll see you tomorrow when i
say skip the speed limit i'm serious you can't
say grant me traveling mercies and then speed